(audience clapping)
Isaiah, there's just something so fresh and beautiful
and romantic about your approach.
What gave you the idea to do it the way you do it?
I mean, I think it's beautiful to see things
through a point of view, first of all,
and obviously I told you last time,
the pandemic was a tough time for a lot of people,
so you know, you just wanna see goodness,
you wanna see kindness during that time
and inspire a lot of people.
So I thought, "You know, I might be the beacon to do it"
and you inspire me a lot too, so.
I'm so relieved, 'cause you really are my example,
(Isaiah laughing)
and I just think you do it
in your own Isaiah way.
Thank you.
And I mean, how many followers do you have on TikTok now?
Like 7 million?
I mean, it's insane.
I have 2 million, like,
(Isaiah laughing)
(audience laughing)
do you know what I mean?
But you're a legend, you have no idea.
But I just, it makes me so happy
that people are in the right place when they're with you.
It's like, I want when people follow someone
to be that example;
we all wanna have fun and entertain and escape,
but to be inspired the way that you are inspiring people
is so amazing.
So you brought something here
today,
Yes.
and so I'm in your passenger seat,
you're the driver, take it away, Isaiah.
Okay guys, so I have this brown paper bag here
and it says "Judy Murphy is the CEO of kindness."
So Judy Murphy is a bagel shop owner
who is doing some incredible things for the community;
just amazing human being, guys.
And one thing that we thought was really, really cool
is Judy actually puts up these brown paper bags
inside of her bagel shop and she puts really cool notes
on 'em like, "$10 for whatever you want in the store"
or "Free coffee" or "Free bagel"
and people who are going through really, really hard times
could just walk up and literally like redeem one
for themself when they're going through hard times;
so she's an amazing human being.
(audience clapping)
She's such a perfect person!
That's the other thing that you do, Isaiah,
is we love you and the way you do it,
but you bring these people into our world.
Yeah.
And someone like Judy and her approach,
you bring it to the forefront; you're telling her story.
And Judy is actually in our audience today, so...
(audience clapping and cheering loudly)
(laughing) Where's Judy at?
Judy, I was wondering if you don't mind
coming up actually
(audience cheering)
onto the stage.
Thank you so much.
Nice to meet you, how are you doing?
I hope we're not catching you too off guard.
(Judy and Isaiah laughing)
We love surprises around here.
How did you find your style?
Because this is what I made for you
and to put your unique stamp,
what was it about the paper bag that gave you the idea?
How did you make this such an artistic, giving,
Judy-stamped approach to all of this?
What was the inspiration?
There were so many people in need in our community
and we just thought it was a simple way.
We just, me and one of my employees came up with it;
we just started writing on bags
and hanging 'em on the wall behind us.
And customers would come in and ask about it
and they'd either take a bag off the wall
or they were paying it forward and they were buying bags
and putting 'em on the wall.
How do you feel like your community
made all this possible?
(sighing) They're amazing.
One gentleman came in and he paid for his $18 bill
with a hundred-dollar bill and he said,
"Keep the change and put bags on the wall."
That's what it's all about.
And every day people are putting bags on the wall
and every day people are coming in, unfortunately,
and taking bags off the wall.
So not only did you kind of come up with this poetic,
beautiful, philanthropic, community-building idea,
but now people are inspired to build on it;
they bring their own bags.
They just say they wanna put a bag on the wall
and we just write up the bag,
or sometimes they'll write up the bag
and decorate it and stick it up on the wall
from the bags we have in the store.
Okay.
And you have said that like, you never know
what tomorrow can bring.
Right.
And so I was interested in what exactly
that meant for you.
My dad died when I was 14;
I was the youngest of four and he suddenly died.
He was a police officer and healthy and he passed away
about a week after he had gotten sick,
and my mother just pulled up the bootstraps
and did what she had to do and you just don't know.
I mean, any one of us could be in a situation
where we need a bag off the wall one day.
Thank you, Judy, for sharing that with us,
really and truly.
Not that it takes away the pain you didn't deserve to have,
but I'm glad that your mother could live on to inspire you
so that you could start a movement yourself.
Yeah, my mom was amazing. (laughing)
She really was.
I just want you to look into our audience right now
because guess what? Everyone has a paper bag
(Judy gasping)
with a message written to you
about how you've
(audience cheering)
inspired us all today.
And that is what I'm talking about, about the poetry.
You've taken this, you know, utilitarian,
beautiful piece of paper.
Thank you so much.
It's like you've turned it back into the tree it once was,
and now it grows into something so beautiful
in honor of the seed you planted.
Thank you, thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thank you for telling your story today
and we also know that you need to keep going
and keeping this movement alive
and the embers and the flames burning,
so our friends at Restaurant Depot have a $5,000 gift card
(Judy gasping)
for you in your bag!
(audience cheering)
For the New York Bagel Company
so you can just continue your mission
of feeding those in need and keeping a behavior
and an artistic approach to taking care of one another.
Thank you so much.
And you know, Isaiah, once again,
thank you for always telling us
these stories, Isaiah.
(audience cheering)
(bright music)